avec 272 voix contre 108 l'assemblée
nationale a adopté la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire ce dernier
devrait donc rester en vigueur jusqu'au
16 février prochain comme le souhaitait
le gouvernement l'assemblée nationale a
donc fait table rase du vote est dit
hier soir des députés de l'opposition
avaient réussi à faire passer un vote le
prolongeant jusqu'au 14 décembre bien
plus tôt donc que ce que souhaitait à
l'exécutif et ce pour la simple raison
qu'au moment du vote et bien la majorité
présidentielle étaient en minorité il
n'y avait tout simplement pas assez de
députés
lrm le texte devrait donc être adoptée
samedi avant un examen au sénat ce jeudi
autres temps forts aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale c'est l'audition
du ministre de la santé pendant 2h30
olivier avérant a répondu aux questions
des députés de la commission denquête
qu'ovide 19 de l'assemblée nationale le
ministre de la santé qui a été interrogé
sur de nombreux dossiers comme la
stratégie de test le nombre de lits de
réanimation ou encore de possibles
erreurs d'anticipation de la deuxième
vague de qu'ovide 19 j'aurais pu
entendre ce reproche si nous étions
restés les bras croisés a répondu à ce
propos le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand qui a précisé avoir toujours été
en phase avec les décisions prises sur
les tests il a par exemple expliqué les
raisons à des retards dans l'obtention à
des résultats
en septembre dernier il a souligné que
le gouvernement avait toujours agi de
manière à garantir la protection de la
population olivier ferrand acquis en
début d'audition avait appelé les
députés à le tenir compte du caractère
évolutif de la situation et les a
appelés à l'humilité le temps politique
n'est pas le temps scientifiques at il
précisé